I think I got drunk on vodka for my 21st
but you couldn't remember but I can't
remember I'm reliving my freshman year
of college
I'm not reliving my freshman year of
college I'm going to judge based on
burning sensation not taste here goes
bring out the vodka first glance there
is no difference the left one has no
smell the right one totally has a
rubbing alcohol smell no this one I want
a clean algae off a fish tank with it's
pretty smooth bark oh that one tastes
like maybe it was sitting in a plastic
bottle no maybe this will be - that one
ha ha much better
look wait no much better that one was
better
really that one was smoother yeah
expensive cheap yeah expensive cheap
okay well then expensive cheap I'm gonna
say this is the more expensive one I say
this is the more expensive one
this was less this is cheap are you
kidding I'm a vodka expert after two
I almost kind of sweet yeah it just
tasted really sharp to me and it was but
it was sharp in like a good way I don't
know
pouch [ __ ] coach Oh God oh no isn't bad
oh no one was good Oh wasn't it was so
smooth no listen this is the more
expensive one really all right I'm gonna
agree with you I'm gonna go sing with
you cheap and expensive I'm gonna say
that's expensive
that one's cheap I'm gonna disagree not
liking the expensive ones at all that's
great that's great that is great
there is why do I feel bad oh no ha
yeah that's like water that is like
water you don't sound like it sounds
like water it's like deep burning water
such a strong gasoline taste yeah
expensive very cheap I agree with you
and say this was this is this is the
more expensive one all right I'm saying
this is Moore's expensive we're gonna go
together yeah yes I got one I'm a cheap
date I'm okay I'm gonna embrace it and
I'm proud of it and thank you guys